The Joe Rogan Experience what do you
think about those scholars in Israel
that believe that the Burning Bush was
some sort of a psychedelic experience oh
well I I think we have no idea how
psychedelic experience shape religious
presumption have you read uh Brian
murillas absolutely I interviewed him oh
yeah I mean look fit
we know that the shamanic tradition
which is
God only knows how many tens of
thousands of years old it might be is it
millions of years old maybe you know
human beings have been using fire for
two million years like it could be
really really old
and the the shamanic tradition is
definitely a psychedelic tradition and
one of the things maresco did was show
quite clearly that the all of Greek
culture was
embedded in what looks like a collective
psychedelic experience and so
yeah I think that I think the evidence
a great religious scholar studied
Shamanism and he thought that the use of
psychedelics was a degeneration of the
original tradition but I don't think
that's true at all I think that the
Psychedelic tradition is part and parcel
of the universal religious Heritage of
mankind and like I don't know what that
means you know I've talked to people
like Robin Carhart Harris who studies
the Neurology of psychedelic experience
and he said that what it does is produce
something akin to uh to a a hyper stress
experience so imagine you're extremely
stressed like your life's in danger and
so you have to open yourself up to the
possibility of radically new ideas well
a psychedelic substance puts you in that
state of mind and so that can be hellish
because you can you can collapse into
like a catastrophic fight-or-flight
defensive response and magnified by the
hallucinogen and you're just in hell but
that isn't only the only necessary
outcome and so the second psychedelic
experience definitely mimics something
like radical learning and it does it
also seems to reduce the effect of
memory on perception
because most of what you see in the
world is memory
it's just a short that's why you know
when you look at a word printed word you
read the word you can't not read the
word that's because you you see in the
memory you're not seeing like when I
look at the sign behind you I'm not lost
in the yellow in the details I see The
Joe Rogan Experience right it's part and
parcel of perception it's all memory
what a psychedelic does in part is
remove the inhibition of memory from
perception
and that reimburses you in the complex
world
and shows you how remarkable and Beyond
Comprehension everything really is
that's real but uh
question is what to do with that you
know Timothy Leary his Doctrine was turn
on tune in turn on Tunein drop out and
that devastated the whole culture of
that idea it's like well if we just shed
our presuppositions and the whole
industrial nightmare we'd all be Freedom
loving hippies wandering around needing
it's like no I wanted to do a line of
psychedelic products uh
turn on tune in grow up right
I think that's much much much funnier
much better yeah and that's also
possible that's a possible path through
this sort of uh quest for Spiritual
Enlightenment yeah and it's not it's the
the Timothy Leary thing was I mean it
was dismissed by a lot of other
psychedelic pioneers of the time they
they saw the flaws oh yeah yeah
definitely the people who are already
experimenting with ideas of proper set
and also do that back in the early 60s
yes and also the people that had no
desire to run a group of like-minded
people which Leary did yeah he wanted to
he fell into that culture that hippie
counterculture and also I think he fell
into the Cult of Personality yeah it
fell into the this thing that happens
when too many people are paying
attention to you yeah you think you have
all the answers yeah it's very dangerous
yeah especially if you combine that with
psychedelics yes yes yes yes that turns
out to be a problem right and the the
intoxicating grip of that the the power
that you have over these people which is
very it's unavoidable and if you are a
guru you know air quotes and you're the
person doing that like how many of them
just start Cults and how many of them
you know it winds up being sexual well
Jung was asked once to comment on
psychedelic experience I think he was
asked about what Huxley was doing and
Jung's answer was beware of unearned
wisdom
right very smart very smart we're very
very smart